[Música]
salud en directo américa de france a 24
me acompaña en el estudio marina sardina
marina vamos a hablar de una muy buena
noticia pero bueno no para nuestra
región sino para las mujeres de escocia
porque ahora tienen derecho legal a los
productos menstruales gratuitos en la
primera ley de este tipo que entra en
vigencia en todo el mundo un paso en la
lucha contra el progreso menstrual que a
su vez también es un tema por supuesto
de salud pública marina bueno diarra o
la cia es es una buena noticia pero
todavía falta mucho para reducir estas
inequidades que se encuentran a la hora
de acceder a productos de higiene
menstrual como toallas sanitarias
tampones copas menstruales y esto es
algo que agrava la salud de millones de
mujeres niñas y adolescentes en todo el
mundo la falta de accesos a productos de
higiene menstrual de seguridad puede
acarrear enfermedades como infecciones
por hongos o bacterias no cambiar las
toallitas sanitarias con frecuencia
también puede contribuir a la retención
y humedad y acelerar el crecimiento de
microorganismos nocivos también raúl
pueden por ejemplo alterar el ph de la
región vaginal y la microflora o
infecciones en el tracto urinario que
muchas veces terminan en complicaciones
graves y esto además de ser una
problemática relacionada con la
desigualdad de género también está
relacionado con el alto coste de estos
productos sanitarios como vemos en
américa latina' este costo de salud
menstrual se equipara por ejemplo un
paquete de 10 toallitas sanitarias tiene
el mismo valor que 2 libras de frijoles
o por ejemplo que un almuerzo común o
una libreta de escuela esto es muy
costoso para millones de mujeres además
125 millones de mujeres y niñas en todo
el mundo no tienen acceso a un inodoro
seguro también 2 de cada 5 niñas en
américa latina' faltan a la escuela
durante su menstruación precisamente por
esta problemática en méxico sólo el 5
por ciento de los padres hablan con sus
hijas sobre este tema y el 16 por ciento
de las niñas y adolescentes tienen
conocimientos precisos sobre la
menstruación raúl clara marina y ejerza
conversación pública a hablar digamos
que la menstruación está mal visto en
muchas sociedades y también genera
incomodidad de algunas personas
relegando la salud de las mujeres a un
segundo plano si así es esto hay una
serie de estigmas y unas problemáticas
que giran en torno al manejo de la
menstruación
olvidado por la salud pública que
debería abordarse también con una
perspectiva de género e intersección
alidad para evitar consecuencias que
pueden profundizar la pobreza o la
desigualdad incluso la de raúl ha pedido
que se reconozca la menstruación como un
problema de salud para hablar de este
tema de esta denominada tasa rosa y sus
efectos sobre la salud tenemos con
nosotros a anais rodríguez ella es
vocera de la organización de
menstruación digna de mexico muchas
gracias por estar con nosotros sana y lo
primero que quería preguntarte que es
esta pobreza menstrual explícanos
hola muchas gracias por la invitación a
todas las personas que nos están viendo
bueno la pobreza mental está compuesta
de tres factores uno la falta de acceso
a los productos de gestión menstrual ya
sea porque no tienes el dinero para
comprarlos o porque no tienes puntos de
venta para adquirirlos no hay muchos
lugares en donde por ejemplo no venden
en la copa menstrual pero tal vez si
puedes encontrar toalla sanitaria el
segundo componente es la falta de
educación menstrual de calidad es decir
no sé si haya pase pero acá en méxico
por ejemplo
escuela primaria de 6 a 12 años que
hablan 20 minutos sobre la menstruación
solamente le hablan a las mujeres
alcance los niños y se acabó no entonces
la falta de una educación objetiva de
manera amigable y que sea para todas las
personas no sólo para las mujeres
también está dentro del concepto de
pobreza menstrual y lo último es la
falta de acceso a las instalaciones
adecuadas que tengas un baño privado que
tengas agua potable todos los días que
tengan acceso a
gestión de residuos etcétera entonces
estos tres componentes hacen lo que
conocemos como pobreza menstrual o la
vena y muy buenos días en 2018 también
en colombia digamos se convirtió en el
primer país de américa latina en quitar
el impuesto agregado en liba las toallas
higiénicas y tampones este año méxico
también aprobó la tasa cero y va cuál es
el panorama en la región de américa
latina y además cómo fue la lucha en
méxico por una menstruación digna
pues mira que en méxico nos inspiramos
mucho en colombia de hecho así empezó
menstruación digna méxico cuando lo
fundé fue porque conocí la experiencia
de colombia y de ahí literal busqué en
google de mexico impuestos toallas y vi
que pagábamos un 16% no es de los más
altos el más alto en américa latina es
22% en uruguay y le sigue argentina y
chile con 19 por ciento de este impuesto
pero aún así como que fueron una
inspiración nos contactamos con
activistas colombianas para saber cómo
había sido su experiencia no repetir los
mismos errores y afortunadamente en dos
años logramos que se eliminara acá la
verdad es una lucha bastante
pues difícil porque al principio como a
lo mejor pasó en colombia pues nadie
hablaba de menstruación abiertamente o
sea ni siquiera en los programas de
televisión en los periódicos ni nada
entonces ir metiendo el tema explicar el
por qué un impuesto sexista
discriminatorio explicar que no había un
bien similar que los hombres necesitaran
y pagarán un impuesto y por eso
necesitaban eliminarlo fue fue un
proceso pues damos dos años de
afortunadamente el año pasado por ahí de
septiembre justamente lo aprobaron en el
congreso de eliminarlo el panorama no
américa latina pues va caminando o sea
en argentina hay muchísimas
organizaciones que están luchando para
que no solamente se elimina el iva sino
también en cuestión de gratuidad en
chile también ya metieron una propuesta
de ley en guatemala también estamos
trabajando con una colectiva entonces
creo que esta lucha es muy reciente
también ténganlo en cuenta sólo son 21
países en el mundo 21 que lograron
eliminar o reducir este impuesto
entonces nos queda mucho camino por
recorrer
anahí también la pobreza es uno de los
factores que hace que las mujeres
accedan a productos anti higiénicos cómo
afecta esto a su salud y a su bienestar
emocional de estas mujeres niñas y
adolescentes de la región
bueno eso es totalmente cierto o sea
nosotros por ejemplo siempre que
hablamos de menstruación decimos que a
obstaculiza el acceso a derecho no sea
por ejemplo piensen en las personas en
situación de calle cómo gestionar la
menstruación o sea que va año van como
donde compran los productos tienen
dinero para comprar los productos acá en
ciudad de méxico precisamente se hizo
una investigación con personas en
situación de calle con mujeres en donde
se les pregunto cómo hacían y de verdad
era que usaban plástico cartón periódico
etcétera y nos comentaban que a veces
tenían que decidir entre comer ese día o
comprar los productos de gestión
menstrual y pues claramente decidían
comer no es por eso que nosotros estamos
empujando como el tema de la gratuidad
porque realmente para muchas personas la
menstruación es un obstáculo
a derechos como la educación ir al
trabajo o sea las mujeres del día a día
y mismo o sea piénsenlo no se vean tan
lejos pensarán yo tengo productos de
gestión menstrual tengo un baño tengo
agua etcétera pero cuántas veces no nos
hacemos nosotras mismas impedido ir a
una reunión o algo porque estamos
nuestro ano y nos da miedo que nos
manchamos la ropa etcétera el estrés
laboral también que eso genera no de
repente estás en una junta y estás
pensando en cómo hay no me vaya ahorita
parar y que esté manchada bla bla bla
entonces todo eso también afecta en
nuestro ti en nuestra vida cotidiana y
es por eso que estamos en la lucha
eliminar el estigma y el tabú en torno a
la administración en torno a eso que
estaba comentando una y según naciones
unidas una de cada diez niñas faltan en
la escuela durante la menstruación
muchas veces por precisamente la falta
de productos higiénicos sanitarios no
cuáles son los principales estigmas y
problemáticas en torno al período
fíjate que en méxico es cuatro de cada
diez niñas faltan a la escuela a causa
de la menstruación hicimos una encuesta
con un listed méxico hace dos años
justamente para matar esto en entornos
escolares y nos dimos cuenta para
empezar que o sea hagan la cuenta rápido
acá en méxico son 10 meses del ciclo
escolar no pongámosle que en promedio
son tres días que mensual que pueden ser
más pueden ser menos entonces si lo
multiplicamos ya son 30 días es un mes
casi un mes entero que las niñas pierden
de ir a la escuela a causa de la
menstruación los conocimientos que en
esos días se dieron difícilmente los van
a recuperar entonces la brecha de género
desde ahí se empieza a ensanchar porque
claramente los niños no faltan a la
escuela y adquieren esos conocimientos
lo que pasa es que llegan a faltar tanto
que llegan a abandonar la escuela por
completo lo cual las pone en una
situación de mayor vulnerabilidad
embarazos no deseados que al final son
violaciones porque son niñas en
matrimonios forzados hasta trata de
trata de personas acá en méxico que
ustedes saben que tenemos como este gran
problema entonces es si afecta muchísimo
parte de lo que matamos es que por
ejemplo no hay instalaciones adecuadas
en las escuelas no hay baños no hay agua
los profesores no las dejan salir más de
una vez al baño los compañeros se burlan
si se llegan a manchar entonces esto es
parte de los estigmas y tabúes que hay
pues bien ahí lamentablemente se nos
acaba el tiempo para seguir hablando de
este tema iguales gracias por estar esta
mañana con nosotros aquí en directo
américa de francés 24 un gran abrazo no
hay una hora hace muchas gracias tengan
un buen día igual para ti anahí
rodríguez vocera de la organización
menstruación digna de mexico marín y de
esa manera entonces ponemos punto final
a este espacio de salud por el día bbl
también por esta semana nos vemos el
lunes con más salud en directo américa
de france 24 y pasamos a saludar a juan
pupiales que nos tiene toda la
actualidad deportiva